[Música]
O
Hélio y también su forma para Laura
Alan Dele Organización Internacional de
Trabajo un extra ese crecimiento
La economía regional de los clientes no era
insuficiente para recuperar el mercado
América Latina tiempo y ver
en la región aquí en esta preocupante Francia
como de costumbre y con perspectiva aumentó a
la informalidad está en esta información para ser
experimentado por crisis de recordarme
registro
10.894 y que él la preocupación económica
de tu mente y el loco no crecimiento
superior a estos pacientes no fue
suficiente desde ayer a 40 mg en este
puede ser trabajo lo que había
perdido en el peor momento de la crisis el 1er
recuperar los cuatro puntos en
común de hombres y mujeres son los
más afectado él siempre el se femenino
sigue girando. 4 por ciento de 2000
pues hay hombres Rural es lo que aporta
amplificar el impacto de la crisis en el
Laura negra para avanzar a tomar el
teléfono celular a
y Pinheiro fue directora regional ella
ocho es para América Latina y él
Quería gracias señor dinero para pensar
que comenzó sin el derecho de América
France 24 sabemos las consecuencias de
princesa y plebeya para ganar 11024 y
cómo afectar a Alagoas naíla Celeste
habilidades sociales y no esta región
así que desde esta habitación 1
es exactamente algo que ella ganó en 2020
había ella todavía puso 10 agujeros.
fue aún peor la historia de la humanidad
tenemos un
hubo cincuenta visiones entonces fue el
siga Helena 2021 no el helio de
Largo Coração Econômica estuvo allí
después de la postal mundial es
hazaña de que era un oficial especial
abriendo Económica E
también
porque el dinamismo que uno así
de esta operación, por mucho que
nuestro país y tenemos dulces figuras de
dos números económicos once por ciento
para el trece por ciento este crecimiento
tiempo insuficiente para recuperarse
números la katharsis usted
fue un crecimiento lo que no la red
Multiplus que estamos pensando
ambos de Cam y eso es todo eso no es
actualmente la mejor persona equivocada
especial y la medida aquí en
calle y crecerá en la tele esto y estos
propinas que no se distribuyen en carrera
luz
eso
si
política podemos 2019 no es mucho
difícil
represión política son los países de
relacionados con la costura cómo transponer el
línea
de bordado y
aumentar no sé
abre personas cercanas y personas
atribuirlo a
si puedes generar descontento y
puede impulsar sus movimientos
de la política estos momentos que yo conozco
que ahora
Vinícius, tú ese grupo negro
pregunta vamos a caminar un poco entonces el
hay más mujeres en particular que
fueron a la farmacia del ladrón en un trámite
y que perdió el intercambio en la pandemia para
ella informaliza porque este castigo en
mujeres que esta mirada determina es
desigualdad y en ella trabajan entre
sombras y morir porque si la persona
nuestras papas fritas
el trato en la punta asi le doy
responder a todo por el morir
en este valor
la cubierta está en su lugar primero estaban
grupo que más
correcto pero se pueden ver subsectores
que tiene un predominio dentro
femenino femenino servicios especiales y
el turismo era más
esta vez en Ceará
película para adultos cuando todos se han ido
que la bala estaba alojada si poemas es
no se trata de tener cuidado con los demás
productos más grandes que quedaron fuera del camino
desproporcionado
acerca de las mujeres
adentro
es este
A B C
asustado de quedarme así ahora como
si vuelves en muchos paises sera
realizado con él tiene uno de ella
yo no quiero
presione entonces es
esto para cumplir 15 años es imperativo
cuota de mercado de las mujeres
igual soy razon de todo y ahora
podemos usarlo se hará de nuevo allí y
También me encargaré de tu análisis.
organización de este evento y el último día
en reproducción no se encontrará
en este momento buscando trabajo en
Orlando encontró Cómo enfrentar esto
crisis si
es exactamente
destruido porque el
sueños cambio Luana agresión tejido yo
Quería el camino de Ronaldo uno
transformación acelerada
hay muchas publicaciones
entonces simplemente dejaron de existir
por lo que es fundamental admitir a estas personas
para otras oportunidades especiales es
rubini clean está en un nivel más alto que
24 por ciento eso también es bastante alto
otro lado esto estoy listo
y la región está pasando por un proceso
de bikini transformación en eso por
seco porque vaca guardamos en este es pa
tenemos que pasar tiene que impresionar y
unicornios Y luego si fundamental eso
hay uno el no es realmente tu
trabajar para aprovechar estos
oportunidades internacionales para
la causa de esto es que tu estas aqui en este
ejemplo yo y esto Dile a la chica esto
protección que es organización
Central internacional quería presentarles
es buscar no se o la 1024
y no año exacto Criciúma si es simple
allá
va a ser económico y regulación
equivocada la de los años y en este caso si
Yo estaba esperando aquí con la reactivación económica
Sería pasta que nunca estamos viviendo
ahi esta
parte de ella está relacionada con esta gorra
¿qué es?
esto sobre
parte de su tierra no tiene 40 años
pasó un grupo y Robin y sus hombres
que salian de la señal
tu profesional y
Hermoso y
el trabaja para farmaceutica
que no tira al norte, no porque
máquina una persona que no logra un e
siempre será mi primera madre tiene un
cuesta uno